[Music]
the culture the food men and the mood
was intense
fun family unfriendly and mostly white
and male the Apollo program was designed
by man for men if we don't acknowledge
the gender bias of the early space
program
it becomes difficult to move past it in
retrospect it's so lucky America was
able to put a man on the moon without
the benefit of diversity or women in the
workplace we're back was people back
then back when we put someone on the
moon I can bet that 99.9999% of all
buildings in the US were built by the
labor of men we need to tear half of
them down and have them rebuilt only by
women otherwise the structures around us
are sexist hashtag structural sexism
d-day June 1944 the culture mostly wide
and male
there are groups like the New York Times
and The Washington Post that believe it
is helpful to diminish America by
attacking individuals and taking away
from their achievements in the name of
diversity in the name of inclusion it
doesn't actually result in more
inclusion it doesn't result in more
diversity but it definitely takes away
from the achievements of American the
people as individuals who did amazing
things deserve to get the credit for it
and they deserve to be lauded for it
this super woke mindset that we're
seeing by The Washington Post and other
members of the mainstream media does a
disservice to the exceptional
achievements of America
you